[Music]
there are many books that did not make
it into the bible
hidden texts of mysterious origins with
bizarre stories
or esoteric teachings the apocrypha
the word apocrypha comes from the greek
adjective apocryphos
meaning obscure which ultimately derives
from the verb
apocryptaein to hide away it's related
to our word
cryptic which means something hidden or
mysterious
so an apocryphal book refers to a text
that is hidden away
and contains secret writings
that said they can't be that secret
because we know that a huge amount of
them existed
the old and new testaments both have
apocryphal books
that were not included into the final
cut to the bible
or in some bibles they were pushed to
the end in some sort of honorable
or should i say dishonorable mention
section aptly titled the apocrypha
so in this video we're going to see what
kind of books were labeled
apocrypha in both the old and new
testaments
the old testament you may have heard of
terms like biblical
canon or canonical texts it simply means
works that a group deems to be
authoritative you'll probably be aware
of some of the canonical books in the
old testament
the book of genesis which contains the
creation of the world adam and eve
noah the stories of abraham isaac and
jacob or the book of exodus
which contains the story of moses and
how the hebrews escaped pharaoh
there's a bunch of other books like
isaiah job
ezekiel jonah and so on we described
these biblical texts as canon
the book of enoch is an example of an
apocryphal text
the book of enoch draws upon a brief
passage in the book of genesis
where he's mentioned once in passing
right before the story of noah in the
great flood
enoch is said to have lived for 365
years
and quote walked with god and he was no
more
for god took him it's a really brief
and unusual account what does it mean to
walk with god
and why did god take him
to answer these questions an unknown
author produced an expansive background
story
embroiling him in a tale of fallen
angels and nephilim
which ultimately led to god flooding the
earth to rid the world of evil
this apocryphal text expands on the
biblical text
in order to supplement it and explain
away any inconsistencies
oh and if you want to learn more about
enoch consider watching my video
on the biblical origins of lucifer after
this video of course
i'll provide a link at the end there are
a great deal of other
apocryphal books in the old testament
the book of jubilees
like enoch expands on the book of
genesis and retells the history of the
world
and of israel but this time introducing
a new calendar
built around the jubilee a period of 49
years
with important days and observances oh
and a few more fallen angels to boot as
well as demons like the mystema
and baleau other texts include
belle and the dragon an additional
chapter to the canonical book of daniel
in it daniel debunks a myth that the
statue to the god bell
is able to eat offerings that it's given
in fact
whilst the king's back is turned the
priests are the ones who eat the
offerings
are passed off as this statue
consequently the priests are swiftly
executed
later it describes how daniel slays a
ferocious dragon
surprisingly however it's not with a
sword but by feeding it enough cakes to
cause it to explode
there's a bunch of other books in the
apocrypha like tobit
judith one and two maccabees and some
others
but above are some of the highlights
these apocryphal texts
were written and circulated around 300
bce
to zero ce and by all accounts they seem
to be quite popular
there are masses of manuscript fragments
of the book of enoch and jubilees from
the dead sea scrolls
so they may have been viewed just as
authoritatively as any other book
in the canon but many of these texts
were written late
and not as established as texts like
genesis and exodus
they simply did not have a long enough
history and tradition behind them
what's more all the talk of fallen
angels in books like enoch and jubilees
may have been too theologically
controversial for them to be officially
canonized
the new testament with the arrival of
christianity came the new testament
and 27 more canonical books the gospels
of matthew mark luke and john
many letters including corinthians and
thessalonians
acts the book of revelation and the list
goes on
this canon was drafted up by the nicene
christians
the more quote-unquote mainstream group
of christianity
from which catholicism protestantism and
eastern orthodoxy
are all descended from their canon is
pretty straightforward
it's the one in your everyday bible but
the new testament apocrypha
largely comes from a group known as the
gnostics
from the greek word gnosticos meaning
having knowledge
gnostic christians were a diverse group
claiming to have secret knowledge about
jesus
passed down through their hidden
apocalypse texts
one of these texts is the gospel of
judas it originally came from egypt and
is dated to 280
ce the badly preserved manuscript
describes a secret conversation between
jesus and judas
judas is told the true nature of christ
and his cosmic role as messiah
it's got some other unusual features
like our god is supposed to be a
luminous ball of light
and how the other disciples apart from
judas have got jesus message entirely
wrong
another example includes the gospel of
mary
again coming from egypt is believed to
have been written in the second century
in it jesus has a conversation about
matters of the soul
with his disciples including mary it's
unsure however
whether it's meant to be the virgin mary
or mary magdalene
but either way she offers a vision of
her own where she describes the ascent
of the soul
into the afterlife these texts as
exciting as they are
were written a lot later than the
canonical gospels
which repent anywhere between 66 to 100
ce
but they do reveal the diversity of
early christianity and some highly
unusual beliefs
yet they pose enough problem for the
nicene christians for theologians like
irenaeus of leon
to have to debunk them in a book
suitably titled on heresies
but there are some texts in the new
testament apocrypha which are a bit
harder to simply discard as being
gnostic
the gospel of thomas is one of them it's
a text that dates to 60 to 140 ce
around the time when the other
soon-to-be canonical gospels were being
written
it contains a bunch of sayings by jesus
114 to be specific
but two-thirds of these sayings crop up
in the other gospels in one form or
another
implying that they were somehow
connected or even had a shared origin
some go as far as to call it a fifth
gospel but others say that it copied
these sayings
from an already completed gospel and so
should be kept in an apocrypha
it was not until far later when a formal
collection of what is
and what isn't canon came about for
example
in christianity a fixed canon came with
the council of rome
in 382 ce during which
the council drafted up a list of all the
canonical books
from the old testament and new testament
and officially
excluded the apocryphal texts from
further consideration
the apocryphal books were considered to
be inauthentic
or simply too controversial to be given
the green light
and were therefore discarded
a final note is that what is and what
isn't canonical
does depend on specific religious
communities
for example the ethiopian church has
enoch in its canon
and because of this they managed to
preserve the book of enoch without this
church
may have been lost to history equally
catholic bibles contain
more books in the old testament than in
protestantism
books like tobit judith and even bell
and the dragon
are one way or another featured in
catholic bibles
in these cases the texts are pseudo
divinely inspired
and shouldn't necessarily be excluded
from the bible entirely
so i hope this gives you a decent
overview of the apocrypha
and what it means to be canonical or
non-canonical as with anything in
biblical studies it can get a little
complex
so add some links below if you want to
learn more i'd love to go into these
texts with more detail
and perhaps dedicate a video or two to a
single apocalypse
like the book of enoch or the gospel of
judas
write below which book you'd like to see
in more detail and i might cover it
and with this video we mark the start of
season two
thanks for your patience everyone i
can't wait to make more videos
and if you're new here why not subscribe
a like and a comment also go a long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye
you